hey what's up my name's Sam leads I'm a
property investor and on this week I'm
gonna be answering some of your property
questions as best I possibly can that
you've commented on YouTube so while I'm
answering these questions if you get
another question that shoots off in the
brain or if you just got something
property finance related something's
bugging you for a while and you want me
to answer comment below on this video
and I'll do my best to answer your
questions next week but right now let's
have a look at what we had last week
Robert John price good morning Sammy
what I've bought and sold nine houses
over the last 11 years congratulations
Robert that sounds like a lot of fun and
hard work we've got to the point where
we own less than seventy thousand pounds
on a two hundred thirty five thousand
pound house cool we could I've got that
figured down two more but we always take
some money out and treat ourselves long
story short I want to use the collateral
in my property to finance on a rental
property I know it's the right thing to
do but with the three young kids I'm
petrified of losing everything do you
think my journey to becoming hopefully
one day being one of the biggest
landlords of the Black Country would be
something your followers would be
interested in watching kind regards Rob
price thank you for your message is
quite a few questions and things in that
so I'll kind of pick it apart so firstly
you've got quite a lot of equity in your
house that's great you mentioned
something about sometimes you draw down
some of the equity to treat yourself and
that's something that I would never ever
ever do because if you're and I know you
experienced so I don't mean to be kind
of like you know speaking in a
patronizing way I know you get it you've
sold a lot of houses and stuff so
congrats but I think when you with
financing house that's debt because all
you're doing is you're just lending
against the house if you use debt to
treat yourself or to buy nice things
like that's just that's just always a
really bad move bad that's really bad
good that's really good so one
suggestion would be 105 about pulling
the money out and put it into properties
in case you lose everything I wouldn't
worry about that personally that's what
most investors do I would we finance and
then I'd use that money to put on as
many deposits as you can in the back
country to go towards your goal and
becoming the biggest in the black
country and ultimately the money is
still there it's just we job
around so if you take money out of a
house and then you put that money into
different houses it's just gonna give
you more cash flow and also give you
more leverage to go up and capital
appreciation so I think that's a smart
move I think that your goal have been
the biggest landlord of the Black
Country is awesome I think it's really
cool I think probably the biggest
landlord of the Black Codes in them it
might be Jim Hobart and he's doing
really good things don't know him super
well personally but I think yeah man
it's possible and of course people would
want to follow the journey so just log
it and documents it tell the world what
you do it and thanks for commenting
thanks for watching my videos and good
luck okay next we have Zack Ismail
thanks Samuel always great content no
problem question if you have only one or
two properties would you recommend
pushing them through a limited company
I appreciate personal circumstances
affects this but a high-level overview
would be good depends on what you're
trying to do so if you it used to be
really hard to buy just one or two
properties in the company back in the
day if you're gonna buy through a
limited company the company has to be
you know have yet to show the the
purpose of the company the accounts of
the company they were really bothered
about the company now they're not
because what happens is you start up a
company and then you can just be a
guarantor to the company there are tax
benefits for buying through a company
namely you can claim your mortgage
expenses as tax-deductible which is
really cool the disadvantages from
buying for a company are you if you just
if you literally only ever want one or
two houses and that's it and your plan
is never to be a big property investor
it just means that if you buy through a
company you're gonna have to pay an
accountant to do your end of tax years
just set the company up in the first
place so is it worth the savings that
you're made from being able to claim the
mortgage payments as tax-deductible
versus how much is going to cost you to
pay an accountant to set it up and to
file your accounts and and and I can't
answer that question because it depends
on the properties it also depends on how
far you want to grow the company
interest rates might be slightly higher
if you're buying through your company as
well not not significantly so there's a
few things to bear in mind generally
speaking if you're looking to grow a
portfolio I would advise buying through
a company it also protects you as well
because because it's the company not you
that owns the property so I mean there's
Kahn's definitely speak to an accountant
okay because it can be so complex but
that's just some advice from my
experience and I hope that helped I'll
go next
father if you enjoyed the video please
do smash the like button as well the
more likes I get the more content I'm
gonna keep putting out there also if you
have a question don't forget to put your
questions in the comments below ok Greg
ushi Greg you Shi Wu ji that's a cool
name I hope I pronounced it right
hey Sammy while I watched your clips now
for years and loved them thank you I
love your name my question is on lease
option agreements I'm from Edinburgh
I've contacted every possible solicitor
and I've been told by most it's not
something that they do I don't know if
it's more difficult in Scotland I even
contacted the Law Society for
recommendation as a possible justice
including commercial I contents them and
just no Joy's please help Thanks alright
firstly if you go to an average
solicitor and you start talking about
Lease Option agreements on residential
properties most solicitors will not know
what you're talking about and they'll
say we don't do that or it sounds a bit
dodgy or they'll say yeah we can do that
but it's not something they specialize
in so generally speaking I would always
go to a solicitor there's been
recommended that specializes in lease
options however in Scotland the rules
are a little different when it comes to
residential property property in general
the rules were a little different
there was a very different in some areas
you cannot pull out of a property deal
so if it with a lease option agreement
if you've got an agreement to buy a
house and say seven years time you can
do it but it's really just a delayed
completion because in England or in most
cases with lease option agreements you
have the option not the obligation to
buy the property whereas in Scotland you
do an option agreement it's actually
just a delayed sale because at the end
of the period of time you have to buy it
ok with residential properties so it's a
little different so my advice would be
either slightly change strategy a little
bit and we can help you do that I mean
if you come down to any of our training
programs the crash course or whatever
whatever program you get to we will
we'll open your eyes up a lot so change
strategy a little bit or just go a few
hours south and work just in places like
Middlesbrough
to be fair I'm doing property deals in
Middlesboro you're probably closer to
Middlesbrough than I am so so you could
invest on the outside of Scotland or
just be a little bit fluid in your
strategy but what you definitely need to
do is stop phoning solicitors in
Scotland asking them if they'll do nice
option agreements because they're always
going to keep saying the same thing as
you've realised what else we got
Hardy path while he says hey dude yo
subdued what's the difference between
ROI and ROC II thanks Hardy okay I'm I'm
imagining that you mean ROI return on
investment ROC a return on cash invested
mmm not e do you know what I've not even
heard of that one before there's a lot
of these different of these different
ones like yield yield is the the annual
rent divided by the value of the house I
just work off of straight return on
investment so maybe I should get a bit
more clued up on some of the other
abbreviations but I don't use them so go
back to the question what's the
difference just stick with return on
investment and you'll be okay I mean
I've done pretty okay so thanks for your
question I appreciate your watching the
videos alright Gonzalo hey what are the
estimated utility bills for rent to
serviced accommodation to bed in Oxford
I'm actually got I think it's a three
bed
I've got a three bed cottage that I use
as rent to essay in Oxford I think I'll
pay around about 400 pounds a month for
the for the utility bill that includes
Wi-Fi and everything so depends on the
house as well the house depends more
than anything in the area because if
it's an old house sometimes you know
depending on on the way it's heated and
things it can be more but about 400 is
what I pay for my 3 bed in Oxford so
that's giving you a ballpark okay we'll
do a couple more Dave
bayar hey Samuel how much do you earn
every month from real estate also if
you're financially free and don't do a
day job does it get a bit boring okay it
can get boring I mean when I first
became financially for I was 21 and I
was making six and a half thousand
pounds I mean that was when I was like
I'm financially free I mean I would take
a boring when I when I kind of retired
effectively I was like I climbed up
Kilimanjaro
I started doing charity work I wrote an
album I learned to play the trumpet I
got to great six and I was just
exploring and in doing stuff I went to
Bible College so I went to understood
for three years so I don't think was
boring but I really what I wanted to do
was just something really that the
brought significance I set up a little
networking group a business network just
to support people in business
particularly people of faith because I
got judged as a Christian people were
like surely you shouldn't be trying to
get money and also so I set up a support
group for that nonprofit and then really
just decided you know what I'm gonna go
actually making money is just adding
value and helping people so I'm really
hard on the property business
how much do I now make a lot of money in
property so I'm looking to make a
million pounds profit of every deal what
I do this year and only one of the two
deals I've got a great cash flow that
comes in you know I employ a lot of
staff and yeah I think that once you get
to the point of financial freedom it
then it's a case of okay well what do I
really want to do you know what I really
enjoy doing so does it get boring I
guess it depends on the person you know
right now you might think if I became
financially free I would just lie on a
beach and retire but probably what
happened is after two weeks of retiring
you just suddenly want to do more and be
more hey so you can't get more man
you've got beautiful kids around alright
we've got really emotional day didn't we
we've talking about purpose the
significance of my a girl came in so
hope that helps I'd love to know your
purpose in the comments why don't you
write down if you became financially
free David Baer and everybody else
watching this what would you do if you
became financially free if you were
making six brenda month passive income
what would you do next let me know
because I'm really curious comment below
and I can help you do that as well and
one of the reasons I train is because I
love seeing what people then go and do
once they become financially free this
is so many rippling effects of goodness
and fruit that happens so it's really
exciting and I'm really honored to be
able to be your YouTube mentor as well
like you know you guys that come on and
watch the YouTube videos come down to
the events as well you know we honored
to be able
serve you and just thank you for
watching and if you haven't subscribed
if you watch and don't subscribe I know
who you are and I will find you so don't
forget to subscribe okay last question
Sunshine Jones if I have no mortgage on
my buy two there am I still adversely
affected by section 24 you're not
affected whether you're indirectly
affected so okay if you've got no
mortgage section 24 all section 24 means
is that you can't claim your mortgage
payments as tax-deductible that's what
it means if you haven't gone mortgage
therefore you haven't got mortgage
payments therefore section 24 doesn't
apply to you so it doesn't apply to you
no but as a result of section 24 rents
are going up a lot of course you're
indirectly be affected by rents going up
in a positive way so there will always
be indirect effects but no nothing you
have to think about because you have not
bought a mortgage although if I was you
I would probably refinance and buy
houses with a mortgage and do it through
a company and claim my mortgage payments
as tax-deductible and make more cash
flow and build more wealth that would
probably be my ninety farmers used
Sunshine Jones but of course it depends
on what you want to achieve so I hope
that helps guys thank you for watching
the video again I really enjoyed reading
the comments I really appreciate the
likes I really appreciate the
subscribers see you next time
[Music]